but I feel like you don't complain out
loud no I don't yeah it's all inside and
I save it up for the same with him the
one I love same he has no complaints
ever I only with me though like you
alright I said right if she gets
everything yeah right so I have to carry
this big bag just diva complaints yeah
yeah and I also don't let it out for
like the first few months of the
relationships that look like once
they're hooked then I let it all out and
it's like it's too late like hooked yeah
you show everything yeah my left foot
you know I have athlete's like a [ __ ]
still no yes but better a little better
now right
but I hit it like a worse sock on that
foot any no sex only a sock on that yeah
once I got that foot I think he probably
has just one bad told me lady doesn't
show yeah I would say down there oh now
it's just yeah yeah a mess yeah but like
you do that's I would be suspicious if
he did trim though I died for sure think
he was cheating on me oh I I totally
agree with that 100% whenever like I go
on an on work trip like if I just like
go away somewhere the first thing Tony
asks me is let me see your [ __ ] because
I'm not gonna shave my [ __ ] on a non
work trip right yeah like wow that's a
good one yeah oh I asked to smell is
dick all the time let me smell your dick
as soon as he walks in the door like let
me smell your dick yeah yeah you smell
your dick all the time garbage if it
doesn't smell like garbage and it smells
awesome
I'm constrain its ya if it's clean she
should be concerned right exactly for
the funk yeah it is I'm looking for your
usual you know shitty penis yeah come on
the best I can not even trimming are you
yeah yeah I am doing my best under the
pressure you were doing her best in the
begin
[Music]
yeah but you just said that doing my
best
I don't think I am either I mean I
definitely haven't worn anything the
luxury of being in a relationship though
right is they love you even I I don't
think they even see like what we're guys
keep it in though I think that they do
notice is because a few weeks ago he
does you know what you could afford to
show more cleavage
that's that's a verbatim what he said to
me okay you should sell yourself a
little better you're on the podcast on
the podcast we do when we do the King
that's not for me
I'm gonna say this right now okay I
swore to God all right
that I love her with all my heart and
when I see her I see my girlfriend but I
also mostly I see family like she's like
a part of me I'm just saying she's a
part of my blood yeah I mean and I would
do anything for her okay and so awkward
babe no that's real I think it's awkward
for you but it's not that awkward for us
yeah I really do when I see her it's
like you mean home yeah that's so sweet
would I really want that or the other
thing but do you like notice when she's
wearing makeup and when she's not no
yeah that's what I mean like I don't I
like that because I mean I wear makeup
probably once a week and partly ten just
tonight further the rest of the week I'm
in pajama pants right and I'm the same
but she's not wearing makeup and she
just you know me she's in the morning
and she has that weird smile with her
cheeks and stuff what is that she says
this like that's your favorite yeah and
it's like oh that's my thing there it is
and their little gap or good like this
like this yeah yeah I got teeth and I go
oh that's what I like that's what I love
that that's love on Netflix off the high
five man yeah man do work again you work
for the show what are we a time
[Music]